first we're going to take some mrna this
will give your body instructions for
your cells to make a spike protein
20 year old jordan treylin says she was
tired of seeing conspiracy theories
about the covid19 vaccine shared on
social media
so she jumped in herself making tick
tock videos and instagram posts
to try to reach her peers with the facts
most people in gen z
my age don't spend their free time
sifting through scientific literature to
try to formulate opinions
about code vaccines and most scientific
matters in general
instead we really look at what's right
in front of us
on our social media and that impacts the
way
that we feel hey guys that prompted
traelins to found the covet campus
coalition
at cornell university the group's
mission is to engage
young adults with catchy posts about the
vaccine
and debunk the myths students at more
than 25 universities are now
participating
despite many u.s colleges and
universities moving to require the
coveted vaccine for students
only about half of young americans under
the age of 25 have so far
gotten a shot doctors caution while
deaths have dramatically fallen in the
u.s
those who continue to die from kovid are
now trending younger
unfortunately despite doing everything
that we can
have had deaths within our hospital from
you know 19 year olds 20 year olds that
sort of thing and so
anytime that happens it's devastating
it's just because a lot of young
individuals
have the mindset that they are
invincible cases involving the more
infectious delta variant are doubling
about every two weeks in the u.s
it's a variant that is more easily
transmissible
potentially deadlier and particularly
dangerous for young people
but the good news is we have the
solution
the science and the data are clear the
best way to protect yourself against
these variants
are to get fully vaccinated the goal now
is to avoid more preventable illness and
death and deny the virus
a breeding ground to develop even more
dangerous strains
heidi jo castro al jazeera washington